now that thanksgiving is over most of us
have turned our attention to holiday
shopping small business saturday kicks
off tomorrow and store owners call this
year crucial as they continue to rebound
from last year's economic hardships
sasha loftis visited a few local
businesses tonight and she joins us live
from the container park in downtown with
more on what we can expect sasha
christian so many are still just really
trying to find their footing after last
year's pandemic shutdowns many here at
container park are using this weekend as
an opportunity to encourage you to shop
here locally
it's a time-honored american tradition
as many including dolores we are head
out and shop till they drop to kick off
the holiday season we just have to make
sure that we take care of our own black
friday is always big but this year many
are focused on supporting local stores
on small business saturday as they
slowly rebound from the covet 19
pandemics economic punch a lot of them
didn't make it those are good laura ryer
who owns las vegas chocolate bar in
container park downtown says the last
year hasn't been easy as a small
business person you just keep going
we just keep moving forward but a recent
lending tree study shows 63 percent of
americans strengthen their small
business loyalty this year angel wong of
four vedas says her shop brings even
more to the table it's more of like
personal it's you know we all get to
know each other that personal touch that
promotes connection while giving our
valley a much needed monetary boost it's
really important that we support our
local communities so if you just can't
wait to spend some cash this weekend
your choice to shop small has the power
to make a huge difference
container park opens tomorrow for small
business saturday at 10 a.m there will
be lots of entertainment and even some
photo opportunities with santa parking
is also free here downtown tomorrow we
of course have more information for you
on our website eightnewsnow.com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now